session of the workshop and we again
have three very exciting talks today
uh my first speaker is uh dr guter kulin
from cwi
he was a senior researcher there in
machine learning
and he'll be talking about pure
exploration problems
all right thank you shibra
so i guess i found that while giving
talks it's much nicer if i
have some audience so all of you that
have just turned off their cameras
because of like
default settings if you wouldn't mind i
have like a panel view here
where all of you can be a little stand
and it's just
the experience is much nicer so if you
don't
have any preference oh thanks very much
oh yeah that's glorious
all right so hi everyone i'll be talking
about
pure exploration problems
let's see so first of all to
maybe pacify the experts
i will only talk about a small subset of
issues
namely i'll only talk about instance
dependent results
in something called the fixed confidence
setting and then i will only look at the
asymptotic
confidence regime okay so
if you don't know what that means don't
worry and if you're upset
i'm gonna you could do something else
all right so for everyone else let's
start so what's pure exploration
okay so my perception is that it's just
a fancy word
for statistical hypothesis testing
and if you you know if you came from the
rl
workshop because that's where we are you
might be thinking about
maximizing rewards but what we're going
to do here is
instead we're going to think about
gaining knowledge
okay and as a as a statistical
hypothesis testing
it's maybe of the you know of the most
amazing glorious type because it's
multiple
testing it's composite testing it's
sequential testing and it's also active
testing
all right so what i will do is i will
first go over
sort of very basic pure exploration
problems
and then make it more complicated so
we'll build up
towards even reinforcement learning
at least a version of reinforcement
learning as a pure exploration problem
and then i'll go into some recent work
and
tell you about some you know this will
be actually quite
brief but some some interesting lessons
learned
okay but that will be mostly advertising
and some high level
uh stuff
okay so let's first go over some
pure exploration examples
okay so the first example is called the
best arm identification
and the starting point here is that we
have a multi-arm banded model
and whenever i don't want to say
anything i will i will always say
bernoulli
but i just say it to get rid of any
questions
so for us um a multi-arm-banded model is
a vector of k bernoulli means
all right and what can we do what are we
going to do with this bandit
well we're going to interact with it
in rounds and the first thing to know is
that
we can decide when we want to stop
okay if we don't stop then we get to
pick an arm
so one of these k arms and we see a
sample from that arm
okay so normally in a bandit you would
treat this as a reward
but we're not going to treat it as a
reward it's just one observation from
this arm
okay so this we keep on doing until we
decide to stop
and then at the very end we recommend
one of the arms
okay so here's that protocol again
so then uh one random variable that is
decided by this
interaction is the time at which we stop
so let's call that tau so that's the
number of rounds after which we decide
to quit
right and if we never quit then let's
say it's infinite
okay so now that's what the learner can
do so what is it
what is a good learner a good learner is
a learner that actually
at the very end outputs the index of the
best arm
okay well you can't do that with
certainty so we're going to allow a
certain error probability
so we say that the learner is delta back
for some
confidence parameter delta if the
probability that the learner makes a
mistake
is at most delta right and this has to
hold no matter which bandit we put the
learner in
and what does it mean to make a mistake
well you have to stop
so tau is less than infinity and you
have to give
the wrong answer so whatever you output
at the end
is not the index of the best arm
okay so if you make mistakes very rarely
your delta pack
and the other thing that we want is that
you actually
recommend something quickly and we'll
call the sample complexity the expected
stopping time
okay so this is a function of mu of the
bandwidth that you're in
and we would like to have an efficient
so that's computationally efficient
delta pack
algorithm that has in some sense a small
sample complexity
all right so that's that goal again
so what would you what would it look
like if you
if you do this and in some sense this is
like a paper template
that you can reapply for all the more
complicated problems
so you you propose some algorithm okay
so that would mean
you write down a stopping rule a sample
rule
and a recommendation rule at the end
and then you first show that it's delta
peg so that it qualifies
as a solution then you maybe
say oh i want it efficient so you show
that it's somehow fast
and then you do the difficult thing
which is to show that its sample
complexity
is actually small right and since we are
going to look at instance dependent
results we would like a bound that looks
like
some function of your instance f of mu
and i already put the typical scaling
here so that will typically multiply
a log one over delta and then some more
stuff that is small
okay so that's what is what you would
like to show
and then to really sort of close the
door on this problem you would show that
if you if you have any delta pack
algorithm
you need at least a certain number of
samples right and if that matches
your upper bound then
you basically solved it right you can
also imagine that you have some constant
vector here maybe
or that you can see that as like a
pre-solution stage
um yeah i think you don't want constant
vectors
okay good
so i just sketched you a problem and i
sketched you what the solution could
look like
so before talking more about solutions
let me first
discuss a bunch of variations of the
problem
okay so there are loads of variations
being discussed
so i try to make it very simple but you
can
do things like uh make different
assumptions about your arms
right so you can say they come from some
exponential family maybe
that i know or you can make try to make
some non-parametric assumptions
like sub gaussian is common but you can
also do it heavy tailed
by just assuming some moment exists
right so all these give new problems in
which you can try to
come up with the solution you can assume
some prior knowledge about
the class of bandits that you're going
to face for example it could be linear
banded lip sheets
you can imagine lots of freedom
you could say i don't really have to
find the best arm i'm happy with an arm
that's epsilon optimal
so you redefine slightly what it means
to make a mistake
now you make a mistake if the arm that
you output has
a mean that is more than epsilon below
the mean of the best
right and you can play with what you
actually observe
when you interact with your bandwidth so
then you talk about something called
feedback graphs
and maybe semi-banded framework
something like that
okay so all these are interesting and i
won't really talk about them
what i want to do is i want to look at
much more major variations of the
of the setup so i'll discuss
um nash equilibria uh
i won't discuss shortest path here but
you'll see from what i show you exactly
how it would fit
i'll discuss a tree search and
solving ndps
okay so so just to make sure that we're
on the same page i'm only discussing
problems right now i haven't told
anything about solutions we will get
there
but i'm just building up a huge stack of
problems
okay so this is the
nash equilibrium identification problem
so what is this so you assume that you
have access
to basically uh a multi-arm bandit
but it's indexed by two
uh finite sets of actions
so you think of this as the payoff
matrix of a game
and then the interaction is exactly as
before except now every round
you get to pick an index in your payoff
matrix
and you see a sample from the
distribution that's behind that
entry okay so it's a stochastic payoff
matrix in each entry there is a
distribution
and you have sample access to it right
so you interact with your bandwidth
until you're satisfied and at the end
you output
two mixed strategies one for each player
okay and we say that your
output is an epsilon approximate nash
equilibrium
if so if you looked at two player games
you will see that this here is the
sub-optimality of both of these
both of b hat and q hat summed so if the
if the gap of your nash equilibrium is
at most
epsilon okay and then the question
becomes
can i make a learner that
um identifies
such an approximate nash equilibrium
right so this is all zero sum by the way
you can do the same not zero zone
um well do you you'll run into hardness
of course
okay so all i'm saying is this is an
interesting
big brother problem of best arm
identification
that we might look at and that we might
try to solve
okay so here is another version it's
also
based on games but it's based on
sequential
interaction instead of parallel
interaction so here we assume that we
have some game tree
and that we have a bernoulli
distribution
in each leaf and we interact with the
bandit by picking leaves and seeing
samples
and at the very end of the interaction
we recommend
one of the children of the root so we're
basically making a claim saying that
in this model for a two player game
the best action for the player in the
route is to go
let's say right right so this could be
an output
of our learner okay and then we can say
well
is the output correct well the optimal
move would be
you know the min max min max the arc min
max inrex
of this tree and you can again say can i
make a learner that output
outputs that optimal solution
with high probability
okay so now let's get to the last one
which is maybe closest to the workshop
which is to solve an mdp
okay so we we have some state space
action space
let's say a fixed start state and what
we don't know
is the rewards distribution let's say
again it's bernoulli
and the transition dynamics which is
some distribution that says where we're
going
if we do a certain action in a certain
state
right and you can do many interaction
models
with your learner and your bandit but
here i picked the one where you pick a
state and an action
right so you don't have to necessarily
go there you can just say
i want to see what this action does in
this state
and then you observe let's say both a
reward sample
and a successor state sample
right you can keep on doing this and at
the very end of the interaction
you output the policy so that's a
mapping that
says in every state which action you
would like to do there
okay and then you can define what is
what is actually the policy that i want
to find
well you typically say uh you have to
sort of talk about
value functions to define it so you
define the value
of of each policy with the usual bellman
equation
and then you say the optimal policy is
the one that maximizes the value in the
start state
okay and then you can say
can i with high probability output this
optimal policy
and how do i do that how do i make a
learner for them
okay so now
what i showed you is a whole bunch of
problems
now let's talk about solutions so i'm
not sure i'm going to reach the top of
the stack
but i'm going to try and build from the
bottom to solve some of these problems
okay so let's go back to best arm
identification
and let's see how we make algorithms and
so we want to say something about the
sample complexity we want to get it
small
but first let's do a lower bound on the
sample complexity
okay and the intuition here is that
if you have an algorithm and it's doing
something
on one banded model and is doing
something else on another banded model
then the only thing that was different
between the two is what the learner saw
so if it has a big difference in
behavior it must be because it
there was a big difference in what the
observations were
okay so if your delta pack on some model
mu
and also delta back on some model lambda
where the best answer is not the same
then you have a very big difference in
what you do
namely you recommend something
completely different at the end
and that means you have to be collecting
a lot of information to discriminate
between those two
okay so let's turn that into a lower
bound
so we're going to say the alternatives
to mu
are all the banded models with a
different best answer
and then this is sort of a very nice
information theoretic lower bound that
says
the if you're delta correct then the
sample complexity that you have on
banded model mu
is some problem dependent uh
constant times log one over delta
and the problem dependent constant is
given by a certain
min max optimization problem where
you're like
you're actually squeezing sort of all
the juice that you can have
out of this uh argument
into a lower bound okay so if you
haven't seen this before i'm not going
to say much more about it but i very
much like this
paper and i recommend you read it
especially the caribbean kaufman one
okay so um
so we see we see now that the sample
complexity is governed by this max min
problem
okay and you can think about it and and
think like what should a good algorithm
do given this
and you can convince yourself that if
you want to match this
your sample proportions on the arms must
actually
be matching this arc max
otherwise you're going to overshoot this
lower bound
so the only way to match this lower
bound is to sample with proportions
but what's called oracle proportions so
this arcmax for w
okay so this leads to an algorithm
scheme
again from garyvee and kaufman where
you try to do exactly that so in each
round
you try to compute w star but you don't
have mu so you do it at an estimate
okay and then you try to sample in such
a way that your sample counts
actually converge to this estimate
and then you try to make sure that your
estimate actually converges by at least
making sure that the mu head converges
to mu
okay and then with some extra magic
for the stopping time and the
recommendation rule you can show that
this actually asymptotically matches
that same lower bound
that we saw okay and if you look in the
analysis
one important thing is that
having the mu heads converge to mu is
not enough you also need that
the w stars as the new heads converge to
the w
stars at mu right so that's a continuity
um and together you can sort of make
everything
chain up and arrive here
okay so why are we interested in
asymptotically optimal algorithms
so one of the reasons is they actually
work quite well
so it depends a little bit on the
problem but in some problems they have
the best
results that i know of and this happens
for example for best arm
and we also have some results or at
least a master student of mine did some
results where he got the
state-of-the-art
mini max gained research results okay so
that's cool so the
asymptotic optimality is actually saying
something even
known asymptotically and then
it's sort of the different style of
algorithms it's not confidence intervals
elimination
don't sampling it's something else right
so it's always good to have more tools
and it says what's really the heart of
the issue
in some sense it's computing w star
right so once you have that you
basically have everything
okay so now let's look at these
interesting points that i was going to
make
so these are sort of recent um
contributions on on top of this
framework
okay so the first thing is about the
continuity
so is the oracle weights continuous
and unfortunately is not always the case
you can sort of fix it if you want with
sort of fancy continuity but
if your problem has a multiple possible
answers for the same bandit
so that happens for example in epsilon
best arm identification
then this attempts don't work
it's really a discontinuous thing
and so what we show is that
you have to change your algorithm a
little bit okay so you can have a lower
bound in the same vein but with an extra
max
and you have a different algorithm
slightly changed
uh it's sort of made sticky so what we
call it
that then matches this lower bound again
but it has to sort of
bypass this discontinuity problem in a
careful way
okay we give some examples where the if
you don't do this stickiness
you're actually suffering
okay but then a second thing
that i wanted to show you is this
lower bounds are based on this max min
problem
okay and there is a nice thing you can
do and that is to observe that you can
solve max main problems
by using online learning so instantiate
learners for max and min
and you have to play against each other
right and this
leads to a slightly different
organization of the algorithm
with two advantages so it's faster and
it composes
nicer so how does it work
you don't know what problem you're in
but you estimate it
and you plug in that estimate in every
round
okay so you have these two online
learners they're learning on this
problem
but you're changing the problem while
they're going
okay but the nice thing is that you only
need to solve to do one round
of online learning for every round of
interacting with the bandit
okay and then you can sort of play nice
games so you can for example
add optimism to your problem to get your
exploration going
and then if you look at all the things
that you have you have for example
regret bound for your learners you did
some concentration you added optimism
all these things sort of nicely add up
and get you
finite confidence guarantees
okay so this is a nice toolbox
and you and you you win computationally
because you only have to do
one online learning step in every round
okay so the last thing
is something about martingales
so with two colleagues from india
we looked at a version of the problem
where we
tried to identify the arm of minimum c
var
so that's again some funny objective
variation not best arm but best sivar
and we tried to do this in a
non-parametric setting with heavy tails
and what happened this was sort of a
surprise is that if you look at this
lower bound and you take its dual
then you get a very nice collection of
martingales
and if you do the mixture method based
on those
you get sort of all the deviation
inequalities that you need for stopping
for free
well not for free but it's sort of
surprisingly nice and
slick okay so i want to conclude with
some
open problems so what i what i hope
is that you know solving a few of these
problems in the end
leads us to um you know understanding so
much how this actually
works in general that we can make
something that i sort of jokingly call
the pure exploration compiler
you basically describe in some formal
system what you wanted to learn
and maybe the assumptions that you have
and it spits out
an optimal algorithm right it's crazy
but also i think it's nice as a goal
to see how far we can push this
and then we also need to understand like
in what cases these asymptotics don't
kick in
and in those cases it's very important
to understand what other problem
parameters are doing
and how we should maybe change our
algorithms to make
those dependences better right and then
[Music]
one motivation for looking at these
problems is they appear as subroutines
for larger systems for example for game
solving or for planning
and what we should do is we should
actually you know
look at the solutions and see how they
interact with the environment
and maybe try to optimize the joint
system and not just these
parts all right thanks
thanks super uh if there are any quick
questions please go ahead and ask them
while the next speaker can set up
so walter i i really i really love this
approach
of starting from the slower band and
trying to like
track the solution that based on your
estimates
but do you think that this can really
scale up
beyond like these discrete cases for
example if you think about like linear
bandit problems
continuous action sets for example do
you think that this methodology is
extensible to
that one
[Music]
so uh
you can you can
right so so one case that i that i do
know a little bit about is when your
your answer set
is continuous so that is typically not
really a problem if you make it into a
decision
version where you say you know as long
as it's epsilon optimal it's good and
otherwise it's wrong
there you can do the lower bound and
it's fine
continuous actions i think it's more
complicated
i haven't looked at it yet
yeah maybe there are people in in the
audience that have tried it
yeah because like in in all these
extensions to
like gain matrices and to end to mdps
these are
these always had some kind of a discrete
structure in them
so i don't know i mean do you think do
you really see this as a fundamental
limitation
or not quite in the end they can
discretize everything
it's gonna work like what's your view on
this scarecrow
on that lines like maybe it would be
nice if some kind of
mean field of products like kale
divergence with some kind of meal field
approximations could
could be utilized maybe that's one one
way to go
[Music]
maybe should we keep this discussion for
the
session i think there is a lot to be
said about around this topic so
maybe it's uh
lillian do you wanna share your screen